estas imágenes no son nuevas en
nicaragua el domingo estas familias se
vieron forzadas a abandonar sus casas
sin saber lo que se encontrarán a su
vuelta sólo dos semanas después del paso
del huracán eta que dejó al menos 200
muertos en centroamérica los
nicaragüenses se ven afectados por la
llegada del nuevo huracán yo está yo que
ve destruida mente completamente sin
nada solo quede con lo que ando ando
puesto sin nada sin nada completamente
en 15 minutos toda destruida mi casa y
ahora comentó no me siento bien amor me
siento con nervio no sólo por mis temo
por toda la gente del muy amor porque
ahora me albergue hay amor para dónde
irnos a meter el huracán yo está ha ido
fortaleciéndose a medida que avanzaba
por el oeste del caribe en su camino
hacia centroamérica se prevé que yo está
alcance vientos de más de 250 kilómetros
por hora a lo largo del norte de
nicaragua honduras guatemala y el sur de
belice el centro nacional de huracanes
de eeuu ha advertido del peligro de
estos vientos y de la lluvia extrema que
podrían ocasionar graves
fundaciones en centroamérica la actual
temporada de huracanes del atlántico ha
roto récords con hasta 30 tormentas
registradas hasta la fecha según los
científicos el cambio climático es el
culpable de la intensidad y la tremenda
fuerza destructiva de los huracanes de
este año